hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick oh
really i'm sorry to hear that man yeah
bullets over broadway was on tv
i came down with a big old diane weast
infection
amy when'd you get here
you've come for my conjugal capabilities
you're looking
real good girl
oop lost a booby and no matter
i'll just build another one
more mashed potatoes
for it
wait for it
901 amy santiago was officially late for
the first time ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh
alarm didn't go up all three alarms all
with battery backup come on who wants to
take this seriously ooh she was taken in
her sleep that's what i'm talking about
super dark boyle but way more plausible
than the sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory i bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9am
why is no one working amy santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why i like to play
i'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
hot damn
damn sir you took that charbonnet to the
house how you feeling let me take stock
my equilibrium is askew my vision is
partially impaired and i'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turn i have something i
need to talk to you about
i might get a promotion to major crimes
they asked me to come in an interview
for a job
what
you're gonna go work for the vulture
have you forgotten how awful he is
the vladimir putin collection yeah 70
bucks a pair and they only increase in
value
[Music]
i guess that's your new best friend now
santiago emphasis on iago backstabber
i'm surprised you read othello what the
hell's othello i'm calling you the
parrot from aladdin
i mean i can teach you guys how to fake
take real drugs like a pro i used to do
it all the time when i was undercover
all you gotta do is close your nostril
when you go down watch this
oh nope
i didn't do it that time i got a full
snout full
okay no let me just try to get them a
little rusty all you got to do just
close the old nosteroni and then oh boy
i got more that time
[Applause]
where did you get this adrian that's
enough oh we can make fake cocaine for
ourselves out of vitamin b powder ooh
vitamin b the second best vitamin guys
i'm telling you the fake snorting can
work what
oh
[Music]
oh i got so much that time
oh
anybody want to listen to jamiroquai
right now okay i'm just gonna move this
away from your nose holes oh well you
two should get going if hawkins tells
you anything text me right away i'll
stay here and watch adrian who's adrian
yeah all right hey yeah do you guys play
an instrument you know i play a little
bit of bazooky anybody else play an
ancient stringed instrument no you guys
want to go to the beach it's a beautiful
day just maybe like get out there throw
the disc around right hey have you ever
been to the statue of liberty captain
have you have you been inside like under
the skirt like what's up there did they
build a you know what i'm saying oh guys
watch this i'm gonna juggle no no no no
no no no no
i gotta find ocampo before rosa does i'm
so wound up i can't focus oh are you
flipping out about tiandra getting
kicked off so you think you can dance
definitely not well you should be her
nae nae was non-puree
i know what's happening
i'm finally hydrated and it's unlocking
my brain's full potential it's too much
for me i'm limitless i don't think water
makes you jittery and does if it's laced
with caffeine
[Music]
dosed my water you just drank 960 cups
of coffee oh that esprit is why i know
talk butter
me having sterk
good luck solving that case
why would you drink more my brain wants
its fast juice the worst part is olson
got away that's the worst part
you could have died man i wasn't hurt
that badly the doctor said all my
bleeding was internal that's where the
blood's supposed to be
oh come here come here you gotta
i'm about to give captain holt his gift
oh did he lift his no gift policy no he
didn't but i figured out a way to buy
him something and trick him into
accepting it you are bad i know right
oh wait you're making fun of me well i
don't care he would never open a gift
right but what if his gift didn't look
like a gift he would open it exactly i
left it in a cardboard box on his desk
there's no card just the words open now
which i wrote with my wrong hand so he
wouldn't recognize my handwriting
captain santiago peralta sir so just to
recap you left an unmarked package on a
police captain's desk on a random monday
with a suspicious message written on
that looked like it was scrawled by a
crazy person
bomb there's a bomb everyone out
let's go this is not a drill let's go
great gift babe
guys guys guys
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you call us in here to tell us that no i
called you in here to change your lives
for you see a mere five minutes ago
hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in oh an identical
mason jar oh this isn't gonna end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're gonna bet on which one happens
first so will hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will skully drink
hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
hitchcock just drank his own fish what
no
i read an article in a medical journal
that said one destabilizing aspect of
the incarceration is the constant
dehumanization rosa you need to be
reminded that you're more than just a
number rosa you are rosa
rosa yep that fixes prison is there
anything we can do to help you anything
you need done on the outside no i'm good
it's not a problem rosa we're here for
you rosa whatever you need rosa
she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting idle so she wants us to take it
out once a day here
i think you should do this you're more
the biker type i've seen you use a
toothpick in public motorcycles are
death machines i have three kids i'm not
risking it are you saying my life
matters less because i don't conform to
society's heteronormative child-centric
ideals are you really playing the gay
card right now yes queen
is uh everything okay santiago no i lost
my ring did you see where it went
actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
monty hall me
it's unbelievable i don't need monty
hall ruining my place of work but monty
hall has already ruined my home life
come on sir the math thing isn't the
problem night shift's keeping you and
kevin apart you two just need a bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
how
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you do that dude his pen up now
he knows problem solved
you